hi I'm Ryan Sumner and I'm with the IBM
cloud team so you're interested in be PC
well today I'm going to tell you how IBM
does V PC virtual private cloud or V PC
allows the user of the cloud environment
to define Virtual Private Networks I
mean if you'd like them control them
tear them down recreate them and then
deploy workloads in to those definitions
so why does that really matter to you
why does it matter to the rest of the
business
well agility security isolation
performance scalability I could go on
and on but first I want to take you
through the building blocks that have
broken out into a few key areas to help
you understand truly what it is the
first building block is all about the
core components that make a V PC V PC is
an isolated logical network that you
create but the first thing that defines
it is where it's located in IBM cloud we
call this location a multi zone region
or an mzr a multi zone region consists
of at least three zones that are
completely fault tolerant locations
within that region that have absolutely
no dependence on the other zone and
allow you to deploy your applications in
a resilient fashion a V PC also defines
at a high level the IP addresses that
will be used for private communication
within that V PC again across that
region these IP addresses are further
used and broken down by allowing you to
create one or more subnets within each
zone so now you're starting to build an
IP network you have complete control
over this create one subnet for a flat
network or introduce segmentation with
multiple subnets again in each zone the
next building block provides a component
to allow you to secure your cloud
deployments security groups are a
network function that allows you to
create rules that will either allow or
deny network communication in out and
around the V PC now that we've created
our V PC and we've secured it we need to
get connectivity to it
IBM cloud provides both public and
private access and different components
to provide connectivity for each of them
for internet or public access we provide
public gateway that's your outbound
access we also provide a floating IP
that you can tie to any of the cloud
resources that you've deployed in your V
PC providing both inbound and outbound
public access for private connectivity
we provide VPN as a service or
traditional direct link private circuits
this is so you can extend your
enterprise into the IBM cloud or you can
even connect your V PC to another V PC
or an outside resource we're getting
close to deploying our workload in V PC
but first let's talk about what network
functions exist to help us with
acceleration and availability IBM cloud
provides a load balancing as a service
which is an application load balancer
capable both HTTP HTTPS with SSL offload
and traditional tcp load balancing
now that we've built our V PC we've
secured it and we have connectivity in
and out of it we can hand it over to our
application teams to deploy their
workloads IBM Cloud V PC is enabled
today for virtual machines and deploy
customizable infrastructure or
kubernetes for those containerized
workloads there are other capabilities
in V PC that provides security like
encrypt a block storage or flexibility
like image import and much more I hope
all these building blocks hope you
understand the value and benefits that
IBM Cloud V PC brings to you in your
public cloud journey thank you if you
have any questions please drop us a line
below if you want to see more videos
like this in the future please like and
subscribe and don't forget you can
always get started on the cloud at no
cost by signing up for a free IBM cloud
account